i wanted to bring up uh andrew clatt
back when
you had tom on your instagram i was
commenting from the king and the sting
instagram
oh yeah what did you say i said the show
should just be called
bad right which i was pretty proud of
actually but yeah hit him pretty hard
he's self-promotion
i like it though yeah this is nick i'm
helping out king of steak
comment whoring gets you a lot of
followers right but uh
then he clapped back and he said uh well
your show should be called yeah man and
coveted boy yeah man
what are you saying yeah man and kobe
well here was one of my favorites too
man well you know what i got
you know i got a lot of hate for this by
the way from bobby bobby tom came on as
a guest on
no no no no no no no no yeah tom came on
whiskey ginger
and we went to the bad friend studio and
tom this was tom's idea
to say that he's going to replace bobby
bobby
i'm not kidding was [ __ ] livid i was
like it's a joke
he's like it's not funny it's not
[ __ ] funny you think you just
replaced me i was like bob
we're kidding if tom of course is not
gonna do the show yeah that's joking
but also bobby was mad so
he's bobby's so oddly fragile he's so
fragile
he's just a delicate little he's like
something you get at the airport and
it's like nice but you're like how do i
keep this plane i got to go two flights
you have to hold it the whole flight
didn't put in a bag i'm tired i'm gonna
go to sleep i took a pill you fall
asleep for
two seconds it's on the floor and it's
cracked already like ah
yeah i had to do i had to do a little
clap back into the king and the sting
rename your show yeah man and culver boy
well that was good
there's another one that's really good
too go to uh
a different pitcher go to go back to his
main uh
and cheetos santino's where you can
where you can follow andrew i'm sure a
lot of you guys already do but
um there was another one you posted
i said that you commented on yeah i
can't remember which one you said
something on
go down a little more maybe or if not
it's that one in the middle maybe right
if i was dylan on our laps if i scroll
down on instagram
through his page it'll probably just
you'll be the type of show where it is
that uh uh okay yeah whatever you think
is best next that's dylan that's me and
then me
rogan and christian holding dylan on our
laps you know what's so funny like that
is a picture that genuinely makes me go
god damn i miss hanging out with friends
doing stand up and [ __ ] around
i mean what like i really that's the
kind of stuff that genuinely when i
scroll past sometimes
it just makes me a little you know a
little soft i go [ __ ] i miss hanging out
and saying hi to people
i think we didn't know how good uh i
think everybody
and this includes everybody for their
own walk of life everybody didn't know
how good we had it oh we had it so good
we did whatever we wanted
is the freest country in the world we're
allowed to do whatever we want all the
time
and then when this happens here you just
goes to show you how restrictive life
can be
when something gets in your way i mean
oh yeah what can you do now we're almost
yeah i feel like we're damn
which one was it go down a little bit
more it could have been that way because
we just he
i remember it just happened okay i don't
remember what it was was that on your
personal account or whatever if it was a
bad friend
it could have been the bad friends
account yeah maybe
maybe it was bad friends it could have
been i was like oh i got asked to do
this show
oh i'm glad bobby found somebody to do
to do this show with him that's what it
was
that's what it was maybe it's a bad
friends episode maybe on that one
no you know what go back to my profile i
bet you it was
that same picture i'm telling you i bet
you the exact same picture with tom
and you said i got i think theo i think
you said i got asked to do this show
i got us to do this show and i said you
already do a show with a handicapped guy
yes
shout out brendan shaw man shout out to
shannon shout out bar door
yeah that's our boy we love barn
barnyard sauerkraut
he's gonna get freaking mad no he's not
yes he will he's that's true you're
right you're right
he knows love there's a big difference
also what did what did uh
go back up in that scroll that what did
uh let me i'm gonna ask you this though
look at that what it did
oh i thought that was somebody else
never mind i was like who
i did that was george who could fight it
might be up at the top
yeah it usually does how why does it
should call it just bad oh he did that
if you think
you get no keep going yeah that's you
again mistake rick and his alcoholic
burn victim friend look at that
nick kept throwing punches he should but
did i comment after that and i commented
that one i don't know
no because i was busy and that is theo's
lying alcoholic burn victim i gotta
yeah yeah i know i know i like that
that's what i love and that's when the
rat king shows up dude but he's gotta
freaking defend his well he doesn't have
a choice evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one